Today,
we're going to turn our attention to the problem of recognizing and,
uh,
restoring hazardous sites.
And you may think that this is a rather minor environmental issue compared to,
uh,
some of the others that are more prominent in your thinking.
Uh,
but,
uh,
uncovering the diversity of sites that have been contaminated in our,
history of success and failure of restoring them,
uh,
reveals that,
within the private sector alone,
there are some 300,000 sites that have been designated by the Environmental
Protection Agency now as requiring restoration within the public sector.
If you look at only three organizations,
the Department of energy that we looked at last week,
formerly the Atomic Energy Commission,
uh,
the Department of Defense and the Department of the interior,
those three departments alone are responsible for 50,000 sites that have been
contaminated
next week.
When we look at agriculture,
we'll see that the repeated application of biocides are pesticides to the same
track of land for the purpose of,
uh,
protecting plants or killing a competitive species that,
these applications are leaving residues in the soil that under many conditions
would classify them.
We're justify classification to also be hazardous sites.
So the idea that simply because their agricultural lands that they're exempt
from the designation is quite interesting,
especially thinking about land conversion,
how easy it is to convert agricultural land to other kinds of more intense land
uses.
That explains a lot of the way that,
uh,
our rural areas have grown over the past century.
So today we're going to take a look at lessons from the Defense Department and
why the Defense Department,
while the Defense Department is pretty interesting to me and that most people
are paying most attention to the problem of private site contamination.
Most of the stories that,
that you may have heard of private sites might include love canal,
uh,
in New York.
Uh,
but every state has its set of private sites that are on a cleanup list.
And every state also has a,
a,
a collection of public sites.
So today we're going to look at the way that environmental law has evolved,
uh,
to identify and to manage these sites,
with a particular eye to what do we do with them in the future.
Uh,
what kinds of uses should we allow?
And that question often relies upon a subordinate question,
which is how risky should the site remain?
How clean should the site be cleaned up?
Uh,
what standard of,
of risks should be applied?
One statute that we'll look at,
we'll include the national environmental policy act of 1969.
Uh,
really a vanguard statute,
uh,
that,
was adopted,
uh,
really at the,
the pinnacle of public concern about a loss of environmental quality,
uh,
the,
riding the,
a,
the beginning of the wave of the environmental movement or the second,
uh,
the second wave really of the environmental movement in the nation.
Uh,
the endangered species act is also relevant often to hazardous site management,
especially on federal lands.
Uh,
why?
Because federal facilities are often in fairly remote areas,
uh,
and those areas often include large amounts of acreage,
that,
uh,
provide habitat for a real diverse set of,
of,
uh,
species.
The clean water act,
also known as the Federal Water Pollution Control Act is often at play in the
identification of these sites in their cleanup because the chemicals that were
released run off into surface waters.
Uh,
the safe drinking water act can also apply,
but we will,
we'll address that later in the,
uh,
in the course as we deal with agricultural chemicals,
as,
uh,
water is either taken from surface supplies and,
and provided for a municipal or community,
uh,
facilities to distribute out to,
for consumption.
Uh,
uh,
but,
also the contamination of underground aquifers is,
is extremely important and we'll touch on that this week.
Uh,
particularly,
uh,
looking at a case on Cape Cod in Massachusetts,
the Massachusetts military reservation,
the resource conservation and Recovery Act,
also known as Rick Rhe Rcra,
uh,
is also at play.
Uh,
that really is a,
a statute designed to monitor chemical release and movement if it is classified
as a hazardous chemical from cradle to grave.
That phrase cradle the grave is important,
uh,
thinking that once you lose track anywhere in the cycle,
it's going to be extremely hard to figure out how you might,
uh,
identify which sites are contaminated and how you,
how you might need to clean it up.
Uh,
the statute today that will concentrate most on will be the Comprehensive
Environmental Response Compensation and Liability Act,
also known as the superfund law.
Uh,
and in this case,
uh,
also,
the case of Puerto Rico that we'll look at today,
uh,
the Wilderness Act is also at play,
as well as the underlying authorizing statute for the creation of fish and
wildlife refugees.
Now,
why would that be?
Well,
it's a,
a quirk in,
in federal environmental law that that many former,
uh,
highly contaminated facilities,
by the Defense Department a especially have been transferred to the jurisdiction
of the fish and wildlife service.
Uh,
they become the holders and the,
and the managers of these facilities,
uh,
in part because they tend to be biologically diverse,
but also for other reasons.
So let's just,
uh,
pause for a minute and take a look at circle.
A comprehensive environmental response.
Compensation and liability act passed in 1980 and then amended in 1986.
It contains certain principles including the polluter pays principle,
the idea that a,
those parties that were responsible should be identified and they should be held
accountable for the cost of cleanup.
So this statute was designed to clean up hazardous waste sites into respond to
hazardous spills and includes mechanisms to clean up abandoned sites or sites
owned by bankrupt parties.
So in many cases,
you find these old factories that,
uh,
have simply moved on,
the corporations have dissolved or they become bankrupt.
Uh,
so who's going to clean them up?
Well,
the Environmental Protection Agency had a fund that was created by circler,
uh,
that,
was generated by attacks on major polluting industries.
So the power industry,
uh,
the,
the coal industry,
the oil industry,
uh,
chipped in to create this trust fund,
that was then used to,
to pay for cleanup in,
in cases where the responsible parties could not be identified.
So first of all,
the sites have to be identified.
Uh,
second of all,
uh,
an investigation takes place in which the government is really the detective
trying to figure out who did what,
when and how serious it was.
So,
uh,
this statute also includes a provision for what is known as joint and several
liability,
uh,
which means that any one responsible party can be held liable for the entire
amount of the cleanup.
So if you put a,
if you contribute,
contributed only 5% of the hazardous chemicals to a site,
then you could still be held accountable for all cleanup costs.
Uh,
but then again,
it would put the onus on how the no one responsible party to track down who
else,
uh,
contributed the other 95%.
So it,
it,
it shifts the burden of,
of,
uh,
the detective work,
to the known responsible party.
Uh,
the statute created something known as a national priorities list.
So you can imagine if we're facing 300,000 private sector sites,
uh,
50,000 known public sector sites under the jurisdiction of only three agencies,
how in the world are we going to figure out which ones we should we need to
concentrate trade on?
Well,
this statute,
uh,
decided that it was going to create a list and I think of this as a listing
statute,
meaning that uh,
uh,
nothing gets attention and let's it unless it gets put on a list.
And by the way,
this is very similar to the safe drinking water act and that uh,
uh,
a chemical will not get any attention.
It won't be monitored by anybody unless it gets on the safe drinking water list
of,
of contaminants in early 93 chemicals on that list.
Uh,
and the endangered species species act is also a listing statute in a sense.
So the species has to be listed.
So in any case where you are identifying a problem and you were putting it on
list,
you're going to have a lot of political resistance,
uh,
to the edition,
the edition to list a,
because it means that someone is going to have to change their behavior either
to,
uh,
pay for restoration or in the case of endangered species,
to be sure that they use the landscape in a way that does not harm the potential
viability,
uh,
reproductive success,
of the species in question.
So these,
these listing statutes,
Safe Drinking Water Act,
endangered species act,
and in this case,
the,
uh,
circla npls lisc national priorities list that they operate by the second same
mechanism,
there's always a fight about whether or not the,
uh,
the problem gets listed.
There's always a fight over who,
uh,
other,
which other responsible parties,
uh,
should be pulled into,
established accountability.
Uh,
and,
uh,
basically,
the lists themselves contain far,
far fewer problems than,
than are actually out there.
Right now.
There are about 3000 potential national priority list sites and a EPA is looking
at about 200 more.
They're likely to be listed.
Uh,
and there are 1200 roughly on the list.
And among those,
since the statute was enacted,
only 773 I had been restored.
And,
and,
uh,
you need to think about,
the word restore and very carefully because it implies that that,
uh,
the site was tested,
after the effort was made to,
uh,
to clean it up and whatever residual chemicals remained a posed an unacceptable
level of risk.
So the idea that,
uh,
you know,
the,
the contaminants could,
could,
uh,
still be on the site.
They could still be in the water,
but they pose an unacceptable level of risk.
This is an important concept and it's a highly debatable concept that,
uh,
is often defined by both a subjective and quantitative metrics.
So 70% of listed sites being restored,
uh,
are being restored by the original polluters.
So that meaning that the responsible parties were identifiable and the remaining
30% account for roughly 50% of the federal funds right now,
because the trust fund,
uh,
that was derived from the tax on industry has gone dry,
went dry in 1995,
and a congress never,
never a restored that fund.
So now,
uh,
the costs have been shifted to the taxpayers,
in the general fund.
So EPA is cost recovery right now,
ranges year to year between about a hundred and $400 million,
but 2000 defense department facilities are,
are exceptionally contaminated.
And among these,
there are certain types of facilities,
uh,
including the,
the,
uh,
training facilities,
where,
uh,
different branches of the military would convene to,
to carry out exercises in preparation for warfare.
Uh,
particularly those that used a live ordinance ordinance means munitions or,
or ammunition.
So that a about 750 training facilities,
uh,
exist in the nation and they cover an area which is quite,
quite large,
about 15 million acres.
So Connecticut,
it's about a 6 million acres in size or maybe actually 3 million acres in size.
Uh,
to give you a sense of the scale of,
of area,
uh,
that,
he's under the jurisdiction of the Defense Department where there is very,
very little doubt about the extent of,
of a cleanup that's necessary on these sites.
It's expected cost more than $20 billion to clean them up,
uh,
and restorations not expected for about 70 years.
Basically,
it's being constrained predominantly by funding.
So for any of these sites,
uh,
and in this case we'll be looking at the defense department and particularly the
navy as the responsible party.
Uh,
there are serious problems of historical reconstruction,
uh,
that are compounded,
particularly by the authority of the Defense Department to maintain classified
information so they don't have to tell us what chemicals they used,
what chemicals they released.
They don't have to tell us the details of the military ordinance that were
dropped,
uh,
or,
or a buried,
uh,
so that they can claim that,
that it would compromise national security objectives if this information were
released.
Uh,
so it's often,
it's often a very difficult to find it out.
How certain is the evidence,
uh,
what's the standard approved?
It's necessary.
Uh,
does the site itself justify environmental restoration?
does it justify individual compensation for people that live near it or worked
on it?
A,
say,
people that,
uh,
worked on,
on firing ranges or people that,
uh,
conducted exercises,
the,
uh,
gis that would storm the beaches a under live fire.
So are they eligible for compensation?
Uh,
what's the value of property that's lost or,
or jobs that were lost in the,
in an area.
So oftentimes when these facilities are,
are,
uh,
located,
they create a boom in the economy and the local economy,
uh,
for example,
in the Roosevelt roads facility was created in Puerto Rico.
Uh,
by the year 2000,
it was generating about $300 million a year in revenue for the Commonwealth of
Puerto Rico.
The base realignment and closure statute that was passed by Congress in 1990,
uh,
designed to really take a careful look and see whether or not,
it,
it really made sense for us to continue having all of these training facilities
all the basis that,
uh,
are sprinkled around the world,
began a process of closing these bases down,
a realigning military activities,
concentrating them,
uh,
at a time when the electronic nature of warfare had evolved to the point where
where weapons guidance and weapons delivery often made,
uh,
the,
the practicing of,
of firing live ammunition,
a really unnecessary,
the precision of the guidance systems really,
uh,
diminished the,
the need for certain kinds of training and the release of certain chemicals.
So the,
uh,
the upshot was in this case that,
the Roosevelt roads base was closed in Puerto Rico and like that $300 million
was taken out of the economy.
So there is a property value loss also associated with these facilities.
Uh,
being recognized to a,
to pose a nuisance and different forms,
uh,
not just in terms of chemical,
released to the environment,
but also in terms of contaminating groundwater or,
or Jason Agricultural lands or the effect of,
of noise.
Uh,
I mean,
have you ever lived next to a,
an army base or an airport,
you know,
that,
uh,
the plane's taking off and Landing Creek,
quite,
quite a nuisance and a,
in this case,
a,
I had a call from a gentleman on Puerto Rico,
uh,
who told me that he was at a training site.
Uh,
just yesterday afternoon.
He was at a training site and,
uh,
he'd worked there for a,
the year between 1968 and 1969 on VA case.
And,
uh,
for often 12,
15 hours a day,
uh,
planes would fly over this site and vomit.
And,
uh,
as far as five,
six miles away,
buildings would shake.
He said his quonset hut,
where his job was to prepare food for four Marines who are training on the
island.
The quonset hut would shake,
the cans would shake.
Uh,
and uh,
it was,
it's quite a,
it's quite disturbing.
So is there a psychological effect there?
So where should the burden of proof of causation lie?
Who should own the knowledge of hazards that are found on the island?
Should this be public or private information?
Many of these questions are similar to the questions that we asked a relative to
the nuclear weapons case.
Uh,
what level environmental restoration should be required and how should national
security interests be balanced against environment,
environmental quality or,
or human health interests,
uh,
over the long run.
Now also you have to recognize that the United States has been in the business
of training troops for,
for,
uh,
its entire history.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
the,
the imposition of,
of,
uh,
you know,
dozens of environmental laws,
uh,
between 1969 in the present,
on that pattern of behavior is quite interesting to follow.
Uh,
how do you think the Defense Department would react to a new clean air act?
that might restrict there.
Dropping a bomb said,
uh,
of course cause air pollution,
when you drop a bomb,
what happens?
Uh,
on the surface you get an explosion,
you get movement of the dust and whatever is on the ground,
the plants,
uh,
the rocks,
the water into the atmosphere.
And,
uh,
you know,
just like the stunt team 90 story,
it goes someplace.
So trying to figure out,
uh,
where it goes and uh,
how to,
how to manage that in a way that,
that protects these additional values of environmental quality and human health
that the defense department really never had to worry about.
So,
you know,
from their perspective,
uh,
the concerns of,
of the environment and health are getting in the way of their pursuit of their
mission.
So under,
under situations like that,
you might wonder,
well,
what would they do?
How would that affect your behavior now?
What would it do to,
uh,
their willingness to disclose what they'd done in the past or to take part in
surveillance to figure out what happened to the,
the chemicals that were released?
Well,
it's going to make them not very happy about it.
And not want to spend a whole lot of money on detecting problems that they are
going to have to deal with.
Basically the,
uh,
the,
the process of environmental monitoring and health surveillance is create,
would create serious problems for them.
Uh,
just as the atomic energy commission realized back in the 1950s in 1960s,
the effect being,
uh,
that,
monitoring and surveillance surveillance often are diminished,
making historical reconstruction or really difficult process to follow.
So that's all with just an introduction to a one case.
And I,
I,
in my career,
I've worked on a variety of,
of,
uh,
military sites,
sprinkled around,
uh,
US territories and,
and,
uh,
thought about,
the,
uh,
the relative contamination among the sites.
And,
uh,
this site is,
is particularly interesting because it is a lies off the east coast of Puerto
Rico.
It's biologically,
uh,
enormously rich.
It has some of the,
the most diverse a cluster of coral species in,
uh,
in the US territories.
Uh,
it also has a,
a variety of,
of different,
uh,
endangered,
species that,
uh,
are terrestrial and marine.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
thinking about,
the way that these laws apply to this site,
uh,
may help you understand some of the problems we face in restoration.
I want to,
I want to actually,
uh,
have you think about what this island was like back in 1939 when the military
decided that they were going to create it.
And when they were actually exploring different bases in the Atlantic.
And,
uh,
they,
they waited until,
uh,
Pearl Harbor,
when the Japanese bombed and,
and,
uh,
you know,
routed the u s navy and,
and many,
many ships,
many lives were lost,
uh,
in 1941.
And they realize that concentration of their troops and their,
their facilities,
their ships in one area was extremely dangerous.
So that they decided they wanted to have an Atlantic basin counterpart,
uh,
to,
to Pearl Harbor.
Uh,
they decided on the eastern coast of Puerto Rico.
And,
uh,
what you can see here is a,
the Roosevelt roads at the head of the,
uh,
head of the era,
which was the core of the base,
a VA case,
and Ku Labor island.
Uh,
so the,
the Roosevelt Road Station,
uh,
is,
a fairly large point that juts out into the Atlantic Ocean and a was highly
suitable for,
for uh,
uh,
birthing aircraft carriers and destroyers.
Uh,
VA case became an island,
a repository for a variety of different weapons systems,
uh,
and they built a perhaps 200 different Walmarts size bunkers,
into the side of the mountains and the hillsides,
uh,
and stored just about every imaginable kind of weapon.
Uh,
at last count,
the last,
the Defense Department a released the information more than 200 different kinds
of munitions ranging from land mines to 500 pounds to 2000 pound bombs that are
about as long as this stage is wide and perhaps about that wide in diameter were
stored there as well as nuclear weapons.
It was one of the largest nuclear weapons repositories,
uh,
in,
in the nation,
uh,
during the period of the Cold War leading up to the,
the sites closure in 2003.
So the,
the process of land acquisition is also interesting because it raises legal
questions that,
uh,
are also a constitutional,
and you can imagine that this island was a owned predominantly by,
uh,
several sugar plantations.
So that,
uh,
23,000 acres of land,
was purchased by the Defense Department.
And,
uh,
although the,
the,
the land itself was,
was owned by only four parties,
uh,
they had fee simple in the land.
It also was the home to several thousand workers who,
who basically lived in agrarian lifestyle.
They were allowed to live on the land.
They had no fee,
right?
They had no legal title to the land.
Uh,
but,
uh,
they had built their houses and,
and sometimes they had three,
five,
eight acres of land and they planted their own vegetable gardens,
a graze their cows or their,
their pigs or their sheep.
They had chickens.
Uh,
and,
uh,
they would,
take their horses down to the coast and,
uh,
they would fish.
So they were extremely poor,
making often,
uh,
less than 50,
$60 a year per person.
And all of a sudden the military decided they were going to take over this base.
And,
and these families were told that they had to leave their land.
They had to leave their houses often with only a 24 or 48 hour notice.
And with very minor compensation for loss of their facilities,
uh,
each family was given a tag.
They were given a tag with a number on it,
uh,
and they were put on the back of a,
a military truck and taken to the center part of the island that is called in
this shot the civilian sector sector.
Uh,
and they were told they should go out into the field and find their new
property,
uh,
that had a stake in the ground with a matching number on their ticket.
So the one of the leaders of the military resistance told me the story that a is
also in the book green intelligence that I,
uh,
I commend to you,
what it was like to be,
uh,
put out into a field and to,
to sleep through tropical downpours,
uh,
with literally no shelter.
So moving from,
uh,
an area that had roads that had water supply,
that had sewage facilities to one that had none of institutional,
uh,
facilities was,
was quite,
uh,
quite wrenching for the society.
So I wondered what it was like,
uh,
back in 1938 and 1940,
before the navy got there.
Wondering if we could establish a baseline on this site to figure out,
uh,
you know,
what had happened to it,
how,
how the ecology might have changed,
uh,
as a,
as a way of thinking about,
uh,
what the landscape might be restored to and,
the,
the area of restoration ecology,
those of you that,
that,
uh,
study this,
know that it's,
it's quite interesting and it's quite a perplexing and trying to figure out what
exactly it is that your restoration,
uh,
that is your restoration goal.
Do you want to restore a,
the species diversity,
the,
the soil quality,
the air quality as it was back in 1940?
Or do you want to try to bring it back to 1900?
Uh,
so that,
uh,
you know,
what your target is,
is,
is difficult.
So,
uh,
I was fortunate enough to,
to obtain a complete set of air photos at,
at a very high resolution,
uh,
that,
you can't see from this shot.
But,
uh,
if you,
if you wanted to,
you could go onto a website that I put together with the map librarian,
a parish here,
work with me for a period of two years collecting all of the imagery of the
island,
uh,
over a period of,
of uh,
between 1940 and 19 and 2000 and in 2008,
uh,
so that now we have this,
this really rich ability to overlay a all the air photographs,
all of the satellite imagery on all the data files that are called geographic
information system overlays on top of one another as a way of thinking about the
ecology of the island,
uh,
how water moves,
how biological diversity has changed and what the,
at least the visible influence of the military might been.
Then we were also lucky enough that a,
the National Oceanic and Admin and atmospheric administration had put together a
gis system for underwater,
for the underwater,
uh,
areas as well.
And,
uh,
then we found that the defense department had mapped with great precision,
the ocean bottom predominantly so that they could navigate among the coral
reefs,
uh,
using,
vessels,
subsurface and also so that they could figure out a trajectories for firing
torpedoes from submarines or other projectiles.
So that a,
the quality of the data for this island is,
is just,
it's a spectacular for anybody that is interested in,
in doing additional research that that might want it historically reconstruct
what was there or what happened to the environment in this site to,
and,
uh,
on the eastern part of the island that became the focus of the training
activities.
Uh,
could I get the lights dimmed a little bit in the back and actually just on the,
on the podium here,
if you look,
uh,
if you look very carefully,
you can see here is the,
the Caribbean coastline.
Uh,
the north side of the island,
which is only a mile,
uh,
of,
of landscape,
uh,
is the Atlantic Ocean.
Uh,
but it's,
it's very,
uh,
low in elevation.
So you can see a lagoon stretching in this direction.
Another lagoon,
a over here and a third over here and a fourth over there.
So it's a very low lying area.
Uh,
so what's really quite striking is thinking about,
uh,
how,
when they were choosing this site as a,
as a bombing range,
uh,
they were not thinking at all about chemical movement or chemical fate.
So what would happen if you drop bombs on this area?
What would happen if you lobbed artillery shells onto it?
Uh,
where would they go?
So these questions were not even close to their thinking.
The island also,
uh,
this,
this is a shot looking back at the western end of the island where the weapon
storage bunkers are a,
and they originally had thought that they would join the island to the mainland,
to Puerto Rico using this long pier.
Here's another shot of the beaches along the island.
A really spectacular beaches on the south side that,
uh,
are,
are clean.
They're,
uh,
they're not chemically damaged.
Uh,
but you know,
occasionally as you dive in these coves or,
or in the bays,
you'll see wreckage of a,
a plane that was down,
uh,
or,
old,
uh,
unexploded bombs that are lying on beneath the surface.
So here's just an example of the kind of,
of a comparative analysis that a you could do over time.
Kind of wondering a how the landscape changed from 1939 over here,
uh,
to 1970 to 1985 and,
into the 1990s,
uh,
where you can see up on the top here a runway.
Uh,
you can see,
uh,
different,
areas where the vegetation has been,
uh,
restricted and,
um,
uh,
either bombed out.
And this shot is a little bit higher in resolution.
Uh,
and you could see that there was a little star here,
which has a surface to air missile site that became a target.
Uh,
and,
uh,
ships would launch their missiles from offshore.
Actually,
historically,
uh,
the,
closer to the present,
you find a that the ships would park further and further off shore,
uh,
as the electronic guidance systems became better.
And,
uh,
more and more of the weapons would actually reach the mainland.
Uh,
the military argued quite vehemently that,
that,
uh,
you know,
we should,
uh,
the nation should accept the ordinance that missed the island.
It was a training ground.
People make errors,
and that's the idea is to,
to,
uh,
to help the pilots and help the,
the,
uh,
the navy and the marines become more precise in their,
their effort to,
uh,
to reach the targets.
They set tanks up on a,
on the hillsides,
the,
they also set tanks and aircraft,
uh,
along runways to become targets.
So this was not a,
uh,
this was not a minor,
intensity of UB target practice and training.
Uh,
I'm going to jump ahead here for a minute.
One example back from 1950 taken out of the New York Times,
uh,
demonstrates that a,
there were 80,000 servicemen that converged on the island,
uh,
in March.
It was a,
a,
a group that consisted of the army,
the air force,
so the,
uh,
the,
the navy,
the marines from the United States,
but also from Great Britain,
from other allied nations.
So that,
uh,
allies would,
get together and try to coordinate,
uh,
land assaults,
era salts and subsurface assaults,
uh,
using live weapons.
They stopped using the adjacent island Culebra and they concentrated additional,
uh,
efforts on VA case,
which further contaminated the island,
uh,
beginning in 1971.
Uh,
one other point I wanted to make about this is that that,
uh,
if the public is trying to figure out and rebuild an image of,
of what it was like and also to understand what the government did,
uh,
it's extremely difficult because the military,
the Defense Department,
uh,
we'll restrict access.
Uh,
their,
their first response would be to,
a request for,
for access would be,
well,
you know,
it really is too dangerous.
Uh,
you,
you can't go on this site.
Uh,
because,
uh,
you know,
there,
there are unexploded weapons,
uh,
and we are the only ones that are trained to identify those and basically to,
figure out,
uh,
you know,
what the chemical risk is a,
so you basically need to trust us.
They would work with their own consulting firms.
Uh,
in fact,
the same consulting firms tend to work at the same kinds of sites around the
nation and they would basically provide reports to people that would be
unverifiable.
So the,
the level of accountability on a site like this is quite low.
The fence that you see here is really symbolic,
uh,
of,
of a limited public access.
How much,
uh,
how much weaponry was dropped on the island?
Well,
this was a basic question and we still don't have a really good answer.
Uh,
we do know that about 200 different types of weapons were released onto the
island.
Uh,
and during the period between 1983 in 1998,
uh,
the Defense Department admitted that about 80 million pounds of,
of,
uh,
ordinance had been dropped on VA case,
so that if you extrapolate a roughly over time and correlate it with their
disclosure of,
of a number of troops and types of exercises that were conducted,
uh,
conservatively,
you could estimate that 150 million pounds of bombs and munitions were dropped.
Destroyers would sit off shore and they would lob these artillery shells onto
the island.
Here is the USS Saratoga sitting off of a VA case,
uh,
practicing softening up the island is the,
a,
the phrase that they use,
uh,
and this would be followed shortly thereafter by troops that would launch a
amphibious vehicles from the holds of large transport ships,
uh,
that would crawl up onto the beach and a release the troops that would then
storm across the island firing machine guns at each other from,
uh,
at,
troops that had invaded the island on its opposite side.
So what's in these weapons?
What was released?
Uh,
what we do know is that a napalm was released and if you've not heard of napalm,
it's a,
it's a horrific weapon.
It's basically gasoline and gel form so that when it's dropped it,
it will ignite and,
uh,
you know,
burn anything that a is near it.
A Agent Orange is another,
uh,
chemical.
It's a combination of two herbicides that became infamous during the Vietnam
War.
Transport planes would fly over Vietnam and they would drop agent orange,
which is a two,
four d and herbicide and two,
four,
five t,
uh,
and the combination wood,
wood,
defoliate,
uh,
thousands of square miles of tropical forest in,
in,
uh,
both north and South Vietnam.
Agent Orange was also used on this island.
Also chaff.
Chaff is interesting and that chaff is designed to jam radar.
Uh,
so chaff is,
is a,
a very small thread.
Uh,
it's a filament,
maybe several millimeters in thickness and to it formerly was wound with a lead
wire,
uh,
in the led would basically reflect radar.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
there were many instances where the San Juan,
Puerto Rico,
uh,
weather stations would be reporting a thunder storms over a VA case,
when in fact,
it was simply a,
uh,
a misread of,
of,
uh,
their radar that was bouncing off of the led chaff,
that would be dropped from these bundles out of the cargo bays over the island.
So led Schaff would eventually just kind of rain down onto the landscape.
So tens of thousands of tons of,
of,
uh,
led chaff would be dropped,
during Ariel,
uh,
air force training exercises in,
in a,
in an attempt to disarm and disorient.
So as one example of the intensity of the attacks during 1978,
about 1500 hours of air to ground bombing occurred,
a hundred thousand missiles were fired onto the island,
a thousand hours of ship to shore bombing.
So in one single year of 5 million pounds of ordinance give you a quick view of,
of an amphibious craft going up over the beach.
This is a small craft of the larger craft,
uh,
could,
could transport 50 to a hundred troops and their hole and they go up over the
beaches,
uh,
raising really interesting questions about the application of the endangered
species act.
Now,
the military argued that,
uh,
the marine amphibious training is much more important than worrying about,
the endangered species,
uh,
that included manatees and Pelicans.
The,
the hawksbill,
the green and the,
uh,
the loggerhead turtle and the turtles.
We're very interesting in this history and that it's long been a site for four
turtles to crawl up onto the beach and dig holes into the sand right at the
right of the base of the dunes.
And the holes that they would dig would be between 18 inches and maybe 36 inches
in depth and they'd lay their eggs in those holes and then they'd crawl off back
to back to the ocean.
It's pretty remarkable in the way that they,
they come back to the same island a year after year and,
uh,
between six and uh,
about 24 weeks later and the eggs hatch,
the little turtles a crawl up to the surface and they wander down to the water's
edge and swim away.
Really quite remarkable.
These three species of turtle,
the hawksbill,
the green and the loggerhead are protected by the endangered species act.
Uh,
at the same time,
the military was a landing.
Their craft on the beach troops would get out.
Uh,
people would be assigned to dig holes,
Berry landmines or a very munitions in the beach.
And,
uh,
in one case,
a former marine told me that yes,
they had varied munitions in the beach and they really didn't have time,
uh,
to pick them up on the way out because they were,
were late for their next assignment.
So they left the munitions,
uh,
buried beneath the beach.
Some of these were detected in 2004 when the fish and wildlife service took over
the area,
uh,
and,
demanded that,
that the most sensitive screening of the beaches,
a curb before they would be opened up to the public.
One other interesting association between the case of nuclear testing and a,
in this case that was purely coincidental,
uh,
was this history of the u s has Killen commissioned in 1944.
So I action in the Pacific in World War II,
particularly in the Philippines.
And it was eventually part of,
uh,
the operation hardtack,
including,
uh,
an operation in Wahoo and umbrella in the Marshall Islands in the new attack,
a toll in 1958 where it was one of those ships that were pulled together,
uh,
and,
and being tested for its resilience.
Well,
you know,
as I mentioned with the,
the case of ships being sprayed by water and that didn't take the radiation out
of the ship,
uh,
than being dragged back to Hunter's point in San Francisco,
for sandblasting,
uh,
they didn't really know what to do with all the ships.
And this one happened to be dragged by barge all the way across the Pacific to
the Panama Canal,
through the Panama Canal up into the Caribbean basin,
and then anchored off of the shore of,
of a VA case for target practice.
So sitting about three quarters of a mile off of the shoreline.
So right now you can see the,
the military base in the background and that Sam missile site I referred to
earlier and the u s has Killen,
he's buried right here.
It really is quite striking.
I,
I'd taken some students down to this site and,
and uh,
uh,
diving beneath it,
you see the hall of the ship,
uh,
you see,
a bombs scattered around it.
You see many old barrels to,
uh,
and uh,
the,
the military is not released.
Uh,
what the,
the content of the barrels is a,
but it's a bit worrisome knowing that the,
the,
uh,
the sand,
that,
uh,
is now in,
it came from the Marshall Islands area.
Uh,
but,
uh,
also it's quite striking that a,
the biological diversity and the region is enormous.
So there was one gun turret that,
uh,
my students and I looked into,
or Barracuda popped his head out of the gun turret tiger sharks that are
sleeping on the,
on the bottom of the,
uh,
the broken up call,
a parrot fish,
Angel Fish,
uh,
just to really alive with,
with different marine species.
It's quite interesting to hear the arguments on the part of the military and
other people that are trying to figure out what to do with,
with uh,
especially in metallic waste.
Uh,
and,
and uh,
uh,
many who have that problem are quite anxious just to go out and use the,
the,
uh,
the ocean as their dump.
And they can demonstrate pretty well that if they build a reef out of an old
ship or old cars that it will serve as a pretty effective habitat for a wide
range of,
of,
uh,
marine species.
Uh,
now this is an interesting example looking off the,
uh,
the coast.
Uh,
the several people wondered,
including a colleague of mine,
Jim Porter,
who's at the University of Georgia.
Uh,
Jim is an ecologist who was trained here at Yale and he's been working on VA
case as well for a number of years.
And the,
the,
uh,
navy tried to explain these circles beneath the surface of the water as being
created by hurricanes,
uh,
rather than being created by a bombs that had been dropped to creating these
craters in the ocean floor.
So their argument was holes in the Va via the can coral reef are caused by
hurricanes.
Well,
you know,
it,
it's really quite apparent that,
uh,
this is not the case.
You see similarly sized holes that are in the landscape.
Uh,
but also,
uh,
Jim went out and,
constructed a robot that would,
would wander through these areas that had a live ordinance,
uh,
lying either within them or next to them.
Uh,
and we took take samples from inside,
uh,
the,
the craters and then from a various distances outside the creator.
I think I have a shot of this.
Yes.
And he actually mapped out the distribution of,
of some heavy metals,
uh,
that,
clearly demonstrated that,
uh,
these were not caused by hurricanes.
Uh,
the navy also claimed that higher levels of lead in the soil or,
or other metals.
Uh,
we're,
we're the cause of dust storms that a blue over from Africa,
uh,
so that,
the,
the island does experience dust storms during certain parts of the year.
In fact,
aircraft navigation is interrupted.
Uh,
but,
uh,
they,
they attempted to confuse the,
the,
uh,
their contribution with natural contribution to the level of,
chemical residue on the island.
There's one shot,
uh,
looking at,
the old barrels inside the rusting hulk of the killing and,
uh,
with,
extremely healthy coral reefs growing right nearby.
An example of napalm,
uh,
being dropped on the island and what that looks like.
Also,
the,
the United States leased out bombing rights and think about the idea of
potentially responsible parties here.
Uh,
if the United States leased out bombing rights to NATO countries and other
allies,
does that infer that they are similarly responsible,
uh,
for restoration costs?
So Canada,
Germany,
France,
Britain,
Chile,
and Argentina all participated on,
on several occasions in,
in coming to the island and,
uh,
joining with the training exercises.
Uh,
there was a website that the military had up,
uh,
for,
a good part of the late 1990s.
Uh,
and they proclaimed a,
that this was a great site for one stop shopping,
so that,
uh,
companies,
US companies,
multinational companies,
including a Raytheon,
General Electric,
Lockheed Martin,
would supply and sell diverse weapon systems on VA case.
Uh,
and it was advertised quite heavily and it,
uh,
had many attractions.
Uh,
these are quotes that it was suitable,
a suitable area for over the beach and Ariel troop movement,
Wifi capability for most nonconventional weapons,
simultaneous conduct of gunnery missile firing.
Uh,
I don't even know what ATG ordinance delivery is.
Amphibious small art,
arms mining and underwater operations,
a missile firing operations,
air to air,
air to surface,
surface to air,
and serves to service.
Uh,
so that by the middle of the 1990s,
the United States was securing about $85 million per year in payments from other
nations,
uh,
to,
gain the right to,
to try these weapons.
So the representatives from Raytheon and,
and uh,
uh,
these other corporations would,
would meet the navy or the air force from other nations and,
and,
uh,
ask them if they would like to try out different kinds of weapons systems.
Uh,
and this further increase the intensity of,
of exercises.
Here's a shot of the weapon storage bunkers that I mentioned that,
uh,
we're designed to,
to basically maintain storage.
These were,
were really interestingly designed.
They were built into the hillside and then they were planted over the top with a
green roofs.
Uh,
you wouldn't think that the Defense Department might have been the first
designer of a green roof,
but in this case,
back in the 1940s in 1950s,
they were building green roofs basically to,
to provide cover so that,
that,
uh,
satellites from the Soviet Union,
or other nations would,
would,
uh,
be fooled into thinking that these were just a small grazing plots,
so that,
uh,
they would lease these lands out to local farmers to graze cattle or goats on
the top of,
of these,
uh,
concrete structures that housed a weapons of all sorts.
The,
the intensity of fire produced a,
an extraordinary mess.
Uh,
and if you look at the surface now of some of these craters,
you see that they tend to fill up with water and you need to imagine what
happens when a bomb explodes on the land and it creates a crater.
It,
it will break itself up into literally billions of microscopic pieces,
uh,
pieces of what pieces of lead,
mercury,
cadmium,
aluminum,
different kinds of explosives,
including,
uh,
RDX,
Hdx,
t and t would be more familiar to you.
But it basically,
uh,
impregnates these chemicals into the side of the crater.
Tropical storms come along and they,
they,
uh,
we'll dump a six,
eight,
10 inches of rain.
On one occasion.
I was there after storm gene hit the island in 2004,
and in a matter of about 48 hours,
nearly two feet of rain had dropped on the island.
Creating those,
those,
uh,
low lying areas,
those lagoons that I had pointed out earlier in the lecture,
basically clearly creating a massive lake in the region.
So here's an example of the edge of one of these craters and you can see the
vegetation growing quite,
uh,
quite well.
Um,
once you get up,
uh,
out of the,
the,
uh,
above the water table area,
and that is in part a function of the fact that that,
uh,
bombs often contain a fairly high level of nitrogen and phosphorous.
So in 2003,
when the base relocation commission close the site down,
uh,
and they stop exploding the vegetation,
it really has come back in full bloom and many different species are now quite
abundant.
And they're growing in these thickets,
uh,
basically making it almost impossible to see what the ordinance would be on the
surface.
So it's more dangerous than it ever was before.
I was standing with a,
uh,
a representative from the house overlooking the site one day,
and he was exclaimed exclaiming how it was coming back,
how it was,
uh,
the site was restoring itself because it appeared to be so green and lush
because of this effect of,
of the fertilizers that were in the,
in the,
in the bonds.
I turned to him and I shook my head,
my head and said,
no,
you completely misunderstand.
It's not restoring itself itself.
The bombs are still beneath the surface,
beneath the vegetation and a,
it needs to be cleaned up.
If you dive beneath the surface,
you can see weapons such as this 2000 pound bomb,
uh,
being a,
measured by a Dr. Porter.
And He's also measured,
uh,
the,
the leakage of the chemicals and the,
uh,
explosives from the bomb into the environment and demonstrated the coral.
The coral are very important and excellent historical records of the chemical
diversity of the area and how it's shifted over time.
So as the coral grows,
uh,
you could test different,
depths from its surface,
and you can come up with a,
a,
a chemical matrix that will give you some idea of what's happened,
uh,
give you a sense as well of what the site looks like after the bombs were
dropped.
Uh,
the vegetation is literally obliterated,
uh,
and,
today,
uh,
it looks quite different than this.
So I'll pause there and we'll come back and take a look at several statutes on
Thursday that are particularly relevant.
Thank you.